Arthur Fleck is afflicted with an
uncontrollable urge to laugh but it's
clear he also has a penchant for cutting
a rug as seen in director Todd Phillips
Joker while keen phoenixes iteration of
the Clown Prince of Crime dances quite
frequently primarily as a means of
self-expression a man who struggles with
mental health issues fails at turning
his love of making other people laugh
into a legitimate career and is often
the target of attacks from strangers
Arthur mostly keeps to himself but when
he's alone he's free to move his feet
and wave his arms as he pleases so wide
all the dancing and Joker Phillips
recently spoke about how that aspect of
Arthur's physicality came to fruition
and why it's important in the film
chatting with collider Phillips
explained that he and Phoenix identified
a certain quality in Arthur Fleck very
early on being that he quote had
musically which manifested itself
through the characters dancing the
filmmaker elaborated it just existed in
him some people that you might know
personally have that feeling and I
always thought that about Arthur but it
was sort of kept in and trapped and
there was something about that evolving
Philips also revealed that a lot of the
dancing in the film wasn't planned out
in the script originally the Joker
script only included Arthur performing
something close to a dance while working
as a sign spinner as seen in the movies
opening sequence later shimmying down
the stairs and his clown makeup and
Joker suits
according to Philips the dancing was
quote something that kind of evolved to
show how the music within Arthur was
fighting to get out when it does each
dance marks an important point along
Arthur's narrative journey he dances
when he feels good about himself and is
totally comfortable with embracing who
he is dur later admitted that he thinks
Joker should have had even more dancing
as he absolutely loved it in the movie
so just pounded joaquin phoenix prepare
for all that dancing well he had a
little help of course though it wouldn't
take a Juilliard graduate or a
professional ballerina to execute the
dance moves
Arthur Fleck did in the film Joker star
Joaquin Phoenix still had do some prep
work to get his character's movements
just right as he revealed to Collider
his dancing prep approach was split into
two parts working with choreographer
Michael Arnold and turning to YouTube to
study people's movements when discussing
the striking scene in which Arthur
struts down some steps Phoenix told
collider I worked with this
choreographer for that but then after
working with him Michael Arnold was his
name I just started watching a lot of
videos of people dancing movement he
later shared with Washington Post that
he was particularly inspired by ray
Bolger an actor dancer Broadway
performer popular in the 1930s
specifically Phoenix drew inspiration
from Bulger's performance of the old
soft shoe and the quote odd arrogance he
displayed through his dancing Arnold had
shown in Phoenix that video which was a
huge part in helping the actor perfect
Arthur's unique manner of moving Phoenix
confessed really I completely just stole
it from Bulger he does this thing of
turning his chin up this choreographer
Michael Arnold showed me that and tons
of videos and I zeroed in on that one
that was Joker right there's an
arrogance to him really that was
probably the greatest influence another
genre of dance that heavily influenced
the dancing in Joker disco though the
jury's still out on whether Phoenix ever
tried to emulate John Travolta in
Saturday Night Fever while preparing for
the film's dance sequences if you've yet
to catch Joker bunnyhop to your local
theatre to learn exactly why some
critics are calling it oscar-worthy
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]